we're going to begin this hour with one
of my favorite segments all year it's
our road to the Grammys where we begin
counting down to music's biggest night
and only on CBS mornings what we get to
do right now is to reveal the recipient
of the 2023 music educator Award
presented by the recording Academy and
the Grammy Museum we are always excited
to announce these annual winners and
this year's winner is High School choir
director Pam Dawson Jamie wax went to
Desoto Texas to meet Dawson and the many
many students who love her
foreign
[Music]
there are sweet sounds in the air around
DeSoto High School
[Music]
coming from a classroom led by a teacher
with a maternal nickname my mama Dawson
I've always been a mama Dawson ever
since I've known it
Pam Dawson has been the choir teacher at
DeSoto since 2007. she expected so much
for me but she helped me to get to those
expectations she treated me like her
child and that's one thing I really
appreciate about her that's where Mama
Dawson is yeah yeah exactly she's
everybody's mother Dawson comes from a
musical family in Detroit Michigan one
of eight kids and the only girl which
she says made her parents overprotective
my mother didn't let me do much so the
only thing I did was practice and she
got good at multiple instruments
including the harp
foreign despite her Talent Dawson didn't
pursue a career in music instead working
office jobs until she was coaxed by a
colleague into teaching got a Friday
those kids that first day and said oh my
God I miss my calling this is it
it's clear that Mama Dawson has embraced
that calling and her lessons go well
beyond notes on a scale you gave a
direction to your choir something to the
effect of go in
strong don't go in timid that seems like
something that is not just about that
performance but it's the way you live
your life it's the way I live my life
and that's what I'm teaching them every
day that it's not about music I'm
teaching them life skills
talk to her students past and present
and they'll agree as far as what she has
brought to the classroom how has that
spilled over into the rest of of your
lives I'm a teacher now
and you know this is my first year
teaching when I go back and I think
about how she made me feel in that class
that's the main thing I want to do in my
classes make people feel welcomed feel
special
you know like we all feel right now
because of her
[Music]
it's a dog eat dog world especially in
the art space and if you are not
um on your on your p's and q's you can
be eaten by the world but she is still
disciplining to us to where we're there
on time before time if you own time
you're late
[Music]
his credit's Mama Dawson for teaching
her to shine a light on her value and
and strengths close your eyes
she's brought me up from a dark place
and and I know she knows that I love her
so much
she built my attitude my confidence
she's always been there
I can't imagine me without her what does
that mean to you
it means that
God has given me this heart
of love
and that's what we're supposed to do as
human beings
we're there to give
[Music]
and sometimes to receive
for years Mama Dawson has asked one
thing of her students when you go away
or fly away and you get your Grammy
make sure you say Miss Dawson was the
one who encouraged me to do this and
follow this and always wanted them to go
and spread their wings and become the
very best that they could be if it were
any of you winning an award like this by
show of hands how many of you would
mention Ms Dawson yeah yes 100 anything
yes of course now it is she who gets to
thank them if it wasn't for them I don't
think I would be where I am so it's
always about the students it's their
time to shine it's their time to get the
glory
[Music]
Miss Dawson in this job you know we're
often able to and lucky enough to
interview people we admire sometimes
even our Idols but every time I get to
do this Grammy piece on the Educators
I'm reminded that these people are the
real heroes the real stars there you go
we've been talking about your piece all
morning David and what a tribute to her
that one of the students said I want to
make people feel the way she made me
feel yeah
music right no this is it I mean we're
talking about Vlad becoming a father we
we have kids I mean this is what you
hope for your child someone to advocate
for them educate them and Inspire them
the way Mama Dawson does but how about
her face when she said I found my
calling yeah that's a great feeling too
we could find something you think this
is what I'm meant to do when you see her
with these kids you know she's where
she's supposed to be thinking over there
it's such a blessing when you find a
teacher like that right I remember my
interpersonal communication teacher
Josette Sarat at turling's Catholic High
School in Lafayette who sort of just
saved me from myself in high school
quite frankly and so why watching that I
just remember teachers can be parents
they can be safe spaces and Mama Dawson
is she's a safe space when you watch
those kids talk about it that's exactly
what they all said kids don't even take
choir go to her class yeah just to be
with her yeah and she's got a great
sense of style too yes she does she
liked her earrings yeah
I liked everything about her
incredible person in a very well
deserved congratulations and tomorrow
our road to the Grammys series continues
Anthony Mason talks to the rock band
Mona skin and you can watch the 65th
annual Grammy Awards this Sunday at 8 pm
Eastern right here on CBS and also CBS
Plus or perinet plus that's what's
called Paramount plus that is what we're
called